If my fever, nausea is an allergic response,
what should I do about it?
If it is an allergic response,
then all you could do for that is to look
at what possibly could be the allergen.
There's other things that could be causing it, of course.
And looking at, like, okay, let me read there.
So this question, my college wants me to go to the emergency,
we get a chest x-ray, blood cultures, urine cultures,
and a respiratory panel.
It'll quite honestly, I'm excited to hear
your oncologist be so diligent about diggy to this,
because you really get that.
So if your fever continues and you continue
to feel really bad, then diggy to get in a chest x-ray
because they're concerned about pneumonia.
So that's what they're looking for,
getting other blood cultures, and urine cultures,
and a respiratory panel to make sure there isn't
some type of other infection in your lungs
would be the right thing to do.
Also remember that having a fever of 101, 102,
well, that's not pleasant whatsoever to go through that,
can put a person in a remission.
So that is literally what at least toxins are,
is that they gave people a toxic culture of bacterial
and viruses that were a mixture of different ones,
not enough of anything to cause serious deadly disease,
but enough to cause a very high fever state.
And when they put these people in high fever states,
their cancers went into remission.
And just saw a news report of Cleveland,
or was it Mayo Clinic a couple of years ago
that was experimenting with this new therapy,
I'm doing the exact same thing that the FDA outlawed
in the 1950s, which was using a culture mix of toxins
to give to people so that they would produce a fever state
and that fever state would thereby stimulate an immune response
to kill the cancer and put people into remission.
Funny, huh?
So when they do it, that's okay,
but when an alternative doctor does it, well, it's voodoo.
So I'm not saying you should just not investigate
the reason why a person has a fever,
continue to investigate by all means,
if you're a oncologist who will need to do those things,
I would follow up and do those things.
But if it calms down and settles down,
then I wouldn't follow up and do anything about it,
probably at all, because it probably was poison
or something like that.
But if it isn't, then at least look at that.
Doesn't mean that you should just run off and take a bunch
of Tylenol to get your fever down to normal either
because all you're doing is artificially lowered your fever,
you're not allowing your body to kill any type of thing
that was going on in the first place
so you actually could be hurting yourself doing that.
No, you don't want your fever to ever get too high
because that can cause damage to your brain cells.